أدركت أن كل ما لدي
تعلمت من حيث علم النفس في
من حيث الحجة من حيث
لغة الجسد من حيث التعبير
العصبية وتعلمت أن كل شيء
لقد علمت أنه ليس لها تأثير و
لم يساعدني كثيرا
عندما يتعلق الأمر بشرح لي
الأب الذي لا يستطيع الذهاب إلى
مكة المكرمة
لأنه تم تشخيص حالته
نخر في القلب وهكذا أعطتني أمي
اتهم منذ ذلك الحين في علم النفس
لإقناعه بالذهاب يمارس الجنس مع نفسه
شفاء لأنه كان أكثر من ذلك بكثير
مهم للحصول على العلاج من
تخاطر بحدوث ذلك له
شيء وعندما أخبرته
أبي أنا ابنته الكبرى و
أني أخبرتها ولكنك تعلم ذلك إذا كنت
اذهب إلى هناك فأنت تخاطر بالموت والمخاطرة
يحدث شيء خطير للغاية
عائلتنا نظر إلي وهو
رفع يديه إلى السماء وقال لي أ
xala وهناك في تلك اللحظة فهمت
أنه على الرغم من التعاطف الذي استطعت
ليثبت على الرغم من كل شيء
تقنيات الاتصال التي كانت لدي
تعلمت الحجة
عندما يكون لدى الشخص القيم
عميقة الجذور من حيث الايمان و
من حيث فهم رغبته
ثم ماذا يمكنني أن أفعل
كل ما يمكنني قوله
كان من المستحيل بالنسبة لي أن أجادل
غير رأيك بشأن ما حدث
مع والدي في ذلك الوقت كان جدا
ذات مغزى لأنه عندما يكون المرء كذلك
كان من وجهة نظره
ثقة كافية به ثقة كافية
في قناعاته لاتخاذ
يخاطر مهما حدث للذهاب إليه
ضد المشورة الطبية و
تحمل مخاطر العيش بشكل كامل
الذي كان له
كثيرا ما نتحدث من حيث
التواصل مع بعضها البعض و
من الجدل حول كيفية النجاح في
ينقل رسالة
التواصل هو المشاركة
تنجح في تبادل الآراء
آراء مختلفة ونتحدث جدا
القليل من التواصل الذي يمكننا الحصول عليه
مع نفسه
كيف يمكن التواصل
بشكل فعال مع الشخص
عندما يكون الاتصال
أنا أحافظ على وجودي مع هذا
شخص كنت أعيش معه منذ ذلك الحين
يعد نقص
ثم ستقول لي لا لا لي
عندما أتحدث أدير بشكل جيد للغاية
التواصل معي ولكن في النهاية ماذا
فعلا
وفي الحقيقة أريد أن أسألك
لأخذ خطوة إلى الوراء
فيما يتعلق بأفكارك وما يتعلق بها
لتلك الرسائل التي ترسلها إليها
كل يوم تعلم أني أتحدث عن هذا
القليل من الصوت داخل ذلك
استمر في تكرار ما يجب أن تحصل عليه
تفعل كذا وكذا ولماذا
ألم أقلها وهي
شيء عندما قال لي ذلك
كان يجب أن أفعل ذلك ، لكنه ليس كذلك
حسنًا ، لديك أبعد ما يمكن أن يكون لديك
ليكون أفضل هذا الصوت الصغير الذي
أسهب باستمرار في الماضي ل
من الواضح اتخاذ خطوة
أفضل التجارب التي مررنا بها على الإطلاق
أنجزه على الفور
يطلب منك أن تتذكر أجمل
يوم من حياتك سوف تربيهم
ذهبت عيون تبحث في الخاص بك
الذاكرة بالضبط ما كان
احلى يوم في حياتك
من ناحية أخرى إذا طلبت منك ذلك
أخبر أسوأ البلاط الذي يمكن أن يخبرك به
للوصول إلى هناك ستخبرني بـ
التفاصيل عن طريق الدخول في
مع مراعاة حواسك الخمس
ستخبرني بما لديك
رأيت أنك ستقول لي ما لك
سمعت ما شعرت به
ربما حتى ما شعرت به
الطريقة الشمية في تلك اللحظة لدينا
الميل لرواية قصتهم
بشكل دائم ويرافقه
هذا الصوت الصغير الذي يوجهنا من
اصبع اليد
قرأت هذه الجملة في مكان ما
قال عندما تشير بإصبعك لا تنسى
ليس فقط لك الحق الذي يشير إليك
ولذا عدت إلى وجهة نظري
لتأسيس الاتصال بنجاح
صحية مع بعضها البعض من أجل أن تكون قادرة على جلب
الحجج التي ستكون مقنعة
يتعلق الأمر بالاتساق أولاً
بحذر إنها مسألة إدارة لإنشاء
التواصل الصحي مع نفسه و
لإسكات هذه الضوضاء العقلية
يذكرنا باستمرار أننا
لم نفعل ما يكفي
ليصنع
ستقول لي في كثير من الأحيان
عندما أفضح هذا وأقول أن
سر السعادة سيكون شيئا
بسيط جدا ولكن في نفس الوقت
الذي يبدو معقدًا للغاية بسبب ذلك
يجعلك تبتسم
سأعطيك إياه على أي حال
لأننا هنا من أجل هذا الحدث و
ذلك وأنه من المهم بعد ذلك
سر السعادة وأود أن أقول أكثر من ذلك
سر مرحلة الاتصال مع
يهمني أنه سيكون التوقف عن التفكير بعد ذلك
سترى جول ومعظم
الوقت نقول م كيف سأفعل
توقف عن التفكير ولكن ما هي
تكلم هذا ثم في الواقع واحد
إنه شيء طبيعي
توقف عن التفكير في أنها ستجعلني في الغالب
توقف عن انتقادي بعد ذلك
أقوم بالتدريس في الجامعة وعندما أقوم بذلك
أقترح هذا التمرين على طلابي
يقدم لهم أن يلاحظوا بشكل عفوي
كل أفكارهم لمدة خمسة
دقائق ونحن ندرك ذلك بالفعل
الفكر والقيود التي نستسلمها
ندرك أننا لا نتذكر مثلي
قال لك أفضل الأشياء
ما كنا قادرين على القيام به ونحن ندرك
أننا نتواصل باستمرار مع أنفسنا
بتوجيه أصابع الاتهام في هذا الرفض
الكبار يخفضون أنفسهم بقول لكن
يا إلهي ولكن متى أفعل
أخيرًا يمكن أن تتطابق مع هذه الصورة
bli ولكن لدي شهرين هو كل شيء
الوقت أثناء البحث عن
تحقيق الأهداف من خلال الوجود
أبحث في الخارج عن ماذا
سوف تكون قادرة على الوصول إلي هذا أخيرا
الاعتراف وأخيرا هذا
مرحلة التواصل مع نفسي ومعنا
ننسى أننا ننسى أننا
نحن بالفعل نصل
أهداف ننسى على سبيل المثال وأنا
إنني أخاطب الجمهور الذي سبق أن حصل على
البكالوريا ننسى ذلك قبل الحصول على البكالوريا
وكان أكثر
غير عادي الذي تم تقديمه إلينا
منذ صغرنا
البكالوريا ثم نلتقي
لتعلم الأشياء التي نستخدمها
حسنا بالنسبة لي على أي حال
اليوم
ليس في مجملها ونحن نتعلم
أنه من الضروري للغاية أن تنجح في الحصول على هذا
البكالوريا بعد حد ذاتها
أدرك أنه بمجرد الحصول عليها
إنه مجرد مفتاح يسمح
للوصول إلى شيء آخر
وبعد ذلك نحن لا نشعر بالامتنان
وجهاً لوجه ، لا نقول لأنفسنا ذلك
أخيرا تمكنا من الوصول
عدة أهداف لماذا لأن
نحن دائما في الإسقاط
لأننا نحاول دائما
لتخبرنا هذه القصة
سيكون أفضل غدا ثم في الحجج
بهذا المعنى فإننا نتحدث عنه
نتحدث عن ذلك مع أصدقائنا للناس في
قال لكنك تعلم هنا لدي كذا وكذا
مشروع سوف أنجح في تحقيق مثل هذا
وكذا وكذا وبعد ذلك في النهاية نحن
ننسى ذلك تدريجيا بفضل
اتبع الأهداف جيدا ننسى ذلك
عش ما يوجد بين هدفين
ما يسمى الحياة ثم
التواصل مع القوة الأخرى
تجادل
هو إظهار التعاطف
تنجح في إظهار اللطف
تنجح في أن تكون في اتفاق كامل مع
الرسالة التي سوف أنقلها
هناك أمامك أنا أ
نقطة اتصال WIFI
نعم أنا نقطة اتصال wifi أرسلها
موجات مثل تلك الخلايا العصبية الخاصة بي
متصل بك بشكل عفوي في
الأورياس
الناس بعض الناس الذين يذهبون
لديك اتصال واسع النطاق و
آخر اتصال أكثر أو أقل
فعالة ثم الشك في أنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك
تريد الاتصال وماذا يحدث
في تلك اللحظة التي لا نستطيع فيها
الاتصال بالشخص الذي معه
نحن نتكلم
حسنًا ، سوف يستغرق الأمر بعض الجهد
إضافي
سوف يتطلب العودة إلى العالم
من ناحية أخرى لإدارة فهمها
من اين انا كيف
سوف أنجح في نقل الرسالة
إلى آخر بكفاءة
كيف سأتمكن من التعبير عن بلدي
آراء وأفكاري لنقل هذا
ما أعنيه حقًا بسبب
النجاح في التواصل هو فوق كل شيء
سعى لنقل رسالة بعد ذلك
للسعي لإقناع الإدانة
جيدا بعد الاعتماد على ما الآخر
سوف تتلقى أنا لست مسؤولا
كيف هو الشخص
سوف يقرأ تفسير ويسجل
كل ما سوف أنقله
نتعرف على مندوب مبيعات جيد من قبله
القدرة على خلق علاقة تعاطفية مع
عملائها ، وأحيانًا على حساب
الشركة التي يعملون فيها
لأنه سيفضل الارتباط هو
سيؤسس مع الشخص أمام
له بدلا من المصالح المالية
وبعد ذلك سوف أنجح في التواصل
عندما أقوم بإنشاء هذا الرابط من هناك
الإحسان عندما سأتحدث عنه
جوقة إلى القلب لأنني عندما أتحدث
من العقلية إلى العقلية بالضرورة يذهب
بعض الصراعات للأسباب
التي رأيناها من قبل
لأن الآخر أمامي أيضًا
يروي قصة
يخبرون بعضهم البعض بكل شيء
القصة التي بناها
محركات داخلية أميل إليها
قارن هذا مع jukebox a jukebox
مثل هذا الصندوق الداخلي mini itx الذي لدينا
في الدماغ
ويعيد السجلات الذهبية بشكل عام
إنها متشابهة إلى حد كبير طوال الوقت
أقراص بترتيب معين
حتى نصل نحن هكذا في
سطح البئر ثم سنقوم بيسون
سنكون أقل نحن أقل ثم نحن
ضرب القاع في وقت ما وبعد ذلك
عندما نصل إلى قاع هذا النقاش متى
حتى حياتي ليست بهذا السوء
ما زلت تمكنت من تحقيق هذا
وكذا وكذا وكذا وبعد ذلك
ثم نعود إلى سطح البئر
في النهاية لا نستفيد حقًا أبدًا
من منزل حمام السباحة
البيئة وبالتالي عندما أنا
يتواصل من عقل إلى عقل عندما
أنا بالتأكيد أحاول أن أنقل بلدي
فكرة عندما تكون نيتي ببساطة
لإقناع الآخر بفرض ماذا
من الواضح أنني أفكر في أنني سأقوم بذلك
تواجه أيضا سلامة
هذا الشخص أمامي إذا لم تكن كذلك
ليس من نفس الرأي مثلي وبالتالي
في ذلك الوقت والنجاح فيه
تحقق من صحة الشخص الذي أمامي
فقط تنجح في القبول
اقبل الاختلاف اقبل ذلك
يمكن لهذا الشخص أن يكون له رأي
مختلف عن لي سوف أنجح
لنقل رسالتي متى
أقبل الآخر ولكي أكون قادرًا
أقبل الآخر الذي سأضطر إليه
اقبلني بنفسي نعود
دائما تهتم لذلك ربما لأن
فقط في مجال عملي
نميل إلى وضع الشخص في
مركز صدمة نفسية كاملة
ولكن بعد ذلك تجربتي
الشخصية
malvy كل ما يمكنني ملاحظة كل شيء
من حولي يقودني إلى هذا الاستنتاج
هناك لا أستطيع أن أكون كليًا
بالاتفاق مع نفسي ومع أولئك الذين
أحيطني فقط عندما أكون في الداخل
تطابق ما بالداخل
مني عندما أتوقف عن إصدار الأحكام على نفسي
عندما أبدأ أخيرًا في علاج نفسي
كأهم شخص
مركزي وعالمي
عند وصولي
أخيرًا إلى حقيقة حقيقية لرفاهيتنا
قل لي نعم ولكن هنا نتحدث عن الأنانية
وأنا لا أستطيع وكيف أفعل وأنا
لا يمكنني التفكير بي أيضًا
فكر في الآخرين
فقط يحدث أن الناس
الذي يحيط بنا جيدًا كما تفكر فيه
هم وهم أيضًا
عندما أقرر وضع الدائرة
الذي ينتقل مني إلى الخارج أنساه
لاستكشاف كل هذا العالم
في الداخل وأنا أنسى أن أستوعب
النظر في كمال وجودي
ومن المؤسف أنه عار
ليعيش حياته مع احيانا
شخص غير معروف لنا
دائما تبحث عن التحقق
المظهر الخارجي للبحث دائمًا في
نظرة الآخرين
كل هؤلاء الآخرين الذين يشكلون
الأسرة بيئتنا الاجتماعية
بيئة ودية التحقق من صحة
ما أنا
عندما كان جاك سالومي الذي قال
ذلك عندما أكون في حاجة
من التأكيد وجيدًا أواجه نفسي
خطر الرفض في ذلك الوقت
ما هو الاهم
هو أن يجادل لنقل
في محاولة بأي ثمن للتأكد من أن
لا أحد يلتزم بما سأقوله أو
لمجرد أن تكون قادرة على التعبير
صحي
من الواضح ما أعتقده ما أنا
أشعر بما أؤمن به
أفضل طريقة بالقبول بالتوازي
حقيقة الآخر
أعلم أن حقائقي بها الكثير
تطورت تغيرت بشكل كبير لدي
اليوم 42 سنة
الحقيقة التي كان لدي في 20 و
بعد التي كانت متجذرة بعمق
لم يعد ما نحن عليه اليوم
نحن نتطور باستمرار وفقًا لـ
خبراتنا على أساس ماذا
يمكن أن يحدث من حولنا
وفقا للتأثيرات الاجتماعية في
اعتمادا على ما تعلمناه من هذه الحكاية
وأحيانًا اعتمادًا على الأشياء
التي لا ندركها حتى
هناك في الخلفية
في وسائل الإعلام على التلفزيون وفي أي مكان آخر
ننصح الجميع بالتوقف
لتغزو كل هذه الأفكار
والتي يمكن أن تكون محدودة في بعض الأحيان
نحن نعتمد كثيرًا على وسائل الإعلام و
في كل هذه المناقشات التي أدعوها
العداد حيث نحاول بأي ثمن
لتحليل العالم بهذا الفكر
الجماعي أنه لن يذهب بعد ذلك
أعيش في تونس منذ أربعة أعوام
سنوات ثم قيل لي ولكن ما هو
ما جئت إلى هنا للقيام به يبدأ بما فيه الكفاية
نسأل السؤال كل يوم
تقريبًا عندما لا أشرح ذلك
في وقت لاحق من السابق وبصحة جيدة
افعل ما جئت إلى هنا لأفعله
هو أن تنجح في نقل
إمكاناتي وقدراتي للجميع
الناس سأكون قادرة على لقاء
سواء في حياتي الخاصة وفي
حياتي المهنية للنجاح فيها
التحقق من صحة كل هذه الإنجازات في البلاد
التي أتيت أخيرًا من و
التي أجدها
أجد الآن وأنا سعيد
لأكون هنا في جندوبة
سأختم بالقول والاقتباس
جملة تأتي من نص
يسمى desiderata وبالتالي في نهاية
هذا النص الجميل وأنا حتى أنت
اقتبس البداية والبداية يقول اذهب
بهدوء بين دين إيلات و
تذكر السلام الذي يمكن
للعيش في صمت دون اغتراب
عش وأكبر قدر ممكن في خير
شروط مع أي شخص وفي النهاية
من هذا النص يقال وانتم
يبدو واضحًا ما إذا كان العالم يتكشف أم لا
لا شك كما يجب أن يحاولوا
لتكون سعيدا شكرا لك
[تصفيق]